okay four people joining the livestream
we are going through a collection of
issues about often language design in
preparation for the release of a new
version language so first up we have
fine character encoding a somewhat
horrifying story of attempting to find
what the encoding in bytes what the
encoding of a byte string is we're just
looking at this and if we take something
like a piece of french the histogram in
isolation one by the way do we have a
list of possible character encodings is
that our character encoding so for
example if I were to do the following if
I were to just take two character code
of that line one thing and each of these
and then I were to say histogram each of
those I'm just curious what it looks
like and whether we think this is
distinguishable or not um you know what
is a plausible histogram here boy this
is taking its time mmm why is it taking
so long
okay there we go
all right so the question is should
machine learning expect to be able to
distinguish right and I mean there is a
subtlety that you know some of the ISO
coatings are very similar because they
you know only defer right the bottom 128
are all the same and should we live
really dangerously let's do a feature
space plot of this thing does that even
have a hope of working of the plots yeah
histograms I mean it'll do something I'm
sure but whether it's at all useful I'd
doubt yeah it's better looking than I
was expecting I think that's kind of
interesting
[Laughter]
how can I get this to look better and
that's a question for features but this
is interesting this is interesting what
happened here it did a surprisingly
interesting job look at that look at
that okay how do I get this to work
better how do I get there to display in
a reasonable way okay but look at this
this is very interesting that this is
grouped like this I think okay so fine
so let's do that
labeled by so what do we want to do we
want to say ah spread you know two
character codes there so sorry that
those histograms
yes want to do an association of percent
nine goes to percent ten something like
that yeah you need to thread that your
association did that okay now you need
association thread or you third it
yourself okay
so chefs yes okay so that's very
interesting
well what I mean this is not as
convincing looking at this picture
because this is all kinds of random junk
out here yeah but but eToys point is
that the shift J gif sir J is and the
uke JP and so on are in the same cluster
as ASCII it's crazy totally crazy well
so I mean I assume that this network is
a recurrent network that is dealing with
sequences not just dealing with the
histogram right that's my understanding
of how it my very limited understanding
of how its implement the problem that
you know Jeremy and I do not have
sufficient expertise in how somebody
from machine learning looked at this so
by the way somebody's asking on the live
stream is it forming clusters around the
same encodings we don't know it looks
kind of crazy to us that that is these
these things that group like EUC
and I saw Latin Cyrillic appear to have
you see is there and so I so Latin
Cyrillic yeah look at that look at that
look at those two well it did a good job
in terms of clustering look at that
they're almost identical that's really
weird
and I wonder so here's yeah so I guess
one thing we need to see oh well one of
the things oh I think there's a problem
because right they like if so to
character code if you don't have the
character in the encoding it puts in
nuttin and I well right so you think
that it's possible but that's not going
to show up in the histogram
exactly Oh that's why some of these
histograms are blank probably okay look
I think we're doing somebody else's
project for them here right um I am
completely unconvinced that this is so
hard
here's the decision tree I'd like to
follow or something um let's ask
somebody from machine learning to just
look at this thing and see whether it
was totally crazy Fair Network okay
second I think we should follow the path
of leaving leaving the find character
encoding future eyes here put character
encoding arrow automatic in to import
documented lightly and put fine
character encoding into the function
repository with the statement that and
when I say document it lightly character
encoding are automatic just say attempts
to find mm-hmm I think that's the usual
find functions yes I agree but I would
argue that there might be some
verification okay ask somebody from
machine learning I think something was
done wrong here that's my that's my
guess okay okay all right let's go to
the next item alright so here I'm
comparing the behavior old question mark
and new question mark it's the old
question just for the sake of a live
streaming audience I would say the point
of this is if you have a file with raw
bytes
can you guess what character encoding
that that file was in so if you're given
a spreadsheet and you're not told the
character encoding by the way how good
are we when we import an XLS file or
something we we read the character
encoding metadata don't we I believe so
and not just that but I believe that the
character encoding is part of the
standard for that format yeah I think so
too and similarly for male right but yet
we see spreadsheet imports that have so
maybe the problem is that people are not
setting
character encoding and the making sense
that somehow it's not getting I mean you
know maybe we have a more upstream
problem that the metadata in these
formats because I'm certainly seen
plenty of spreadsheet imports that have
wrong character encodings perhaps it's
worth just taking a quick look at what's
going on with that for example I
remember that the whatever it is the
meteorites example in the data
repository was an example of one that
was I think a spreadsheet import that
had the wrong character encoding so my
question is how could that possibly
happen if the spreadsheet itself has
correct character encoding metadata
makes sense I mean it may depend on
whether it's an actual spreadsheet or if
it's just a CSV or TSV file or something
that's true yeah CSV TSV those are the
candidates where or pure text file are
candidates where we would not have
metadata right so yeah there actually is
another issue if we want to go in for
this we have three groups of functions
that take a character encoding
oh sorry formats three loops of formats
you have the text-based ones that take a
kid that take a character encoding
option so there there's the there's the
text ones you know CSV TSV actual text
we have HTML where automatic means at
least at the present time what automatic
means is basically look at various
different places where the character
encoding might be specified in HTML and
then we have grid sorry table and list
which currently just assumed assumed ISO
latin-1 and you can sorry for which what
you're talking about for import formats
for what
import formats which take a character
including option so we have my table and
grid we have table and list okay we
which assume ISO Latin one for import
then we have the the various text
formats which are you know text CSV TSB
and then we have HTML and on some level
right so the question was do we want to
you know really make automatic be you
know auto-detect or do you want a
special string called other detect and
then automatic for these other formats
for which you know there's a different
automatic behavior you can which is
primarily HTML you can say automatic
there or do you want this look automatic
okay so one question is read it from the
metadata right right which is more like
it could be an automatic could be an
inherited hmm no I think that if there
is metadata automatic means read it from
the metadata okay there probably could
be a you know the question is should
there be a representative should there
be a setting that says go try and deduce
this even if it's not on the metadata
right well let's get it to work better
before we do that okay but I agree you
should remember that point so that we
remember that in so when we document it
in character encoding in the character
encoding option will say automatic means
either get it from the metadata or if
there isn't metadata try to deduce it
from the content okay all right on to
the next issue dollar post and question
mark this appear this is got to be a
corner case what is it right so if you
said so the thing is question mark used
to print
sited you know print wasn't subject to
dollar post but if you now set dollar
post then information will do whatever
right it's now returning things which
well those question mark do the same as
information yes that was the point we
were going for although we could you
know we could make it a magic form which
behaves differently right so I I think
are two main possibilities is either
question mark and double question mark
are okay or we make the magic and here's
what I would he was is what I'd really
like okay just like we have special you
know pausing forms like equal sign like
greater than sign what I'd really like
is to have question mark be one of those
so that I could type in here any old
stuff right and have that be a general
way to get help that's what we planned
in version one actually it's the way it
worked in SMP back in version you know
and - eight years ten years whatever it
was well I think that that would be okay
so I admit that I just made this up
because I'd remembered you know the
previous goal in other words what I'm
suggesting here is that this like equal
sign is an escape to something where you
can just type any old stuff where you're
not constrained by the standard pausing
because that's a paused thing that does
you know that does that right okay fine
well auto stratification is fine I'm
just suggesting maybe question mark
should actually have a visual feedback
in the notebook front end
why because
I mean because I mean you have
autocomplete you have you know oh I mean
look if you're asking do I care about
the corner case of dollar posts the
answer is I don't think I care about the
corner case and what is this doing here
internal that's just a way to call the
old version of information I wish this
wasn't so ugly yeah I mean it's a
particularly bad case because the usage
message for plot is generated from the
documentation so it's string if I'd
boxes so how should we be doing that is
there optimization of those things that
we could easily write so in terms of
function usage we basically have either
the usage message or the at least for
the things that we have documentation in
rough pages for we have the sella Fayyad
version or the boxA fied versions of
them that like the code assist raft uses
yeah in terms of input form they're all
going to look a little messy you know if
that was for you know plot style instead
of a function it would the usage message
would be pretty clean since it'd just be
a string it wouldn't need to be raw
boxes probably as long as you want it to
look all pretty like that then it has to
be typeset boxes whether it's linear
syntax or actual boxes
sorry I got distracted for a second
could you repeat as long as you want the
usage to look pretty it needs to be
boxes whether that's linear syntax or
typeset boxes why wouldn't it be just
typeset boxes here why does it have to
be a string well but I mean you'd see
the input form of the boxes right I mean
you're not going to see something pretty
either way
yeah well what so this would be two
boxes of that is that right no it would
be probably make expression of two boxes
of that sorry two boxes of make
expression of that and it doesn't even
parse
so would it would be right well it would
be exactly what you would see if you
were to unform at that cell right good
show here yes if you unfun that that
cell oh gosh oh no that's still that
cell the string for why on earth is this
string at fight that's my question
it's a usage message and messages this
is really looking back into the deep you
know atavistic and trails of the
previous generations of goats yeah it's
the tricky part about modifying a
function introduced in version 1 is we
get a fair bit of history that comes
along with it well look I don't care
about the corner case of dollar post I
think there's some cleanup that could be
done around all of this which we may be
forced which may be forced upon us by
function repository documentation and
things like this but I think let's not
let's not worry about this particular
thing right now another case that I'm
not seeing are you about to tell me
about other horrifying cases weren't we
redoing the the formatting here what
happened to that that is the redone do
we have somebody from design
because I thought we'd agreed to put
this on the left Heidi should be here
Heidi with us yeah I'm here I agreed to
put the drop down on the left no no no
no the label on the left we talked about
putting it as a tab there and decided it
was no it's too heavy this is still too
heavy
yep did you is this your redesign
version or not it's close yeah it's not
quite exactly what I have Nick still
working on it well as Nick can you
comment on that it's Nick here yeah I'm
here I mean please send me yeah sure I
just think this would look better on the
left I don't understand why we're not
doing it on the left well what's that
that's a one line change
no I realize that I mean I unless
there's some things silly about this but
Lincoln said well I think your your gray
is like significantly lighter here did
you spec the the gray level yeah we
passed gray levels look we're still
working on those final little details
okay and I don't know that the plot that
folding of flood is doable probably
doable it may not be desirable okay well
do a ball in any robust fashion that we
would want to actually do and Jeremy
asked me to put the opener closer at the
bottom of the pod but I didn't get to
that before the meeting doesn't make us
stripy look yeah yes good idea well I
don't know something but what is that
the opener for
it's already open if you click on it and
the actual thing it'll close right so
that's the difference between question
mark and double question mark so what is
John I want you to put that once it's
opened it would go to the bottom ah very
good good idea yes I think you should
try this on the left could you try it on
the left unless you have a good reason
to not do that both this and the opener
also is this really the size we settled
on it looks big maybe it's maybe took
maybe it's just because I have oh I see
maybe my magnification didn't magnify
this did you get what I'm saying that's
weird is that really right do we really
want that smaller size and do we want
that smaller line spacing between the
entries here am I making sense okay the
font seems too small here and the inter
line spacing the inter element inter you
know usage message spacing seems too
small well isn't it the same
yeah but I think if you increased it to
the amount of space space that look
that's what it is in the current version
something has gone wrong here okay the
font is slightly smaller right so it
should be the same size
I would prefer slightly more letting
between the between the you know usage
message elements if the amount of blue
that you have above the first plot and
below the last yeah for example would be
good okay my other complaint is in here
I think these look very computer istic
and I think they could look better with
it with a maybe slightly bolder or
something those links we've went around
and around about whether we should go to
code font or use a source sans
Jeremie thought we should use code just
because it's their code based it would
be appropriate here I don't think it
looks very good nobody thinks it looks
very good well then we shouldn't use it
then we should go to the non if if the
non code phone is going to look good
then that's what we should use okay same
as we're using up here so do we have a
way to compare the two not in real time
we're really going to go over this do we
have more to go over on this if so we
should probably get Jeremy here we have
we have in terms of visuals while I'm
Acharya it depends on what your reaction
will be to the other visual design and
we also have a couple of behavior
questions I think the political design
of these ones looks quite good I mean I
think it could go to the left with a
cloud object thing and it still look
good I think you refresh the design I
put the labels on the left the only
thing it does is it throws the openers
and closures kind of off no they should
be on the left as well okay okay and and
and this should align with the text I
think
could the opener go in the head where
this where it says symbol
well I was trying to keep in in you know
stride with what we had done before with
audio and not reinvent user interfaces
every road new thing um could could we
try to get Jeremy yeah
you
so these down here okay let me just keep
looking at these
these look really quite good that's a
big thing it's a big thing that's a big
amount of information and that file
thing yeah that's the updated version of
file information so we forget all the
extra parameters we didn't have you ID
go to space Senate uh that that's an
oversight there's an auto auto decaying
for camelcase properties and it's just
missing a new ID okay
and this basically this list is
comprehensive to what we have at the
moment I have to say I really think that
this should have a plus and a morph or
something of this size well I don't know
I mean this is information you're asking
for so I think we should consider in the
future having a plus with more okay but
I think this looks very good whatever I
mean some of these are a little bit
funky yeah for the most part we tried to
focus on expressions we already have an
information function for and the next
pass would be looking at all the things
like interpreters and other things where
we don't currently have a an information
function I don'ts done this we have like
hundreds of properties so this is this
is the entity summary information so
this is similar to the the summary pods
we serve then we need a link to get to
more entity information somehow okay
like to the entity data set or something
because it makes it look like this is
all we have right yeah I mean we
we don't want to populate everything we
have about Germany when you ask for it
out of the box otherwise we could say
something like summary in this
information thing but I think it would
be really good to have a link of some
kind to the full you know dataset query
saying mm-hmm so at least some
indication that there's more information
available yes but at the very least um
we could put the word summary somehow in
this yellow box here or something yeah I
mean entity is the only special case we
have right now where we're giving a
subset of all data because we have the
ability to have that curated set of
major properties for each domain so
these are the qualifiers for the
property so you're looking at you said
give me information about the population
property for City and this is a
breakdown of the qualifiers that are
available that's really weird
no that seems completely wrong wait a
minute the first thing that we should
have that this isn't right this is a
question for Alan and Tony what to do
for this case because the first thing we
should say is you know the
characteristics of this entity property
before we start yakking on about its
attributes mm-hmm see what I'm saying
and that there should be a header here
that indicates that those are the
attributes you get what I'm saying
yeah I mean the the parent information
for the property it doesn't display
there because it gets put in the the
second the subheading box where it says
city population is it also includes the
type in the name no I'm well aware of
that I'm saying before we start yakking
about the subcases
we want to say things like units or
nodes we want to do yes right here okay
we go off onto this stuff okay
yeah it's kind of wrong and this is
wrong okay that's just wrong doing that
and I would say I you know you gotta ask
come
who knows what's actually in these
things okay and Jeremy's here Stephen
okay Jeremy we're still talking about
whether these headings should be to the
left and we're I'm not really happy with
where do we have them yeah this it seems
way too small this is the old one that's
the new one seemed good yeah yeah I mean
it I think it's too smaller I think
there should be more letting between the
okay
yeah but now what we're discussing is
whether this should go to the left as it
is here what do you think and if it does
go to the left I think we've discussed
is having this footer
down at the bottom like this I do like
it left
seems like it stands out less which is
probably good right and it can go
slightly lighter gray as Heidi has it
and there hasn't been followed here
I think this size is right for this but
this stuff should go to larger makes
honest yep
this could be light a light gray and hmm
I think that will be okay now down here
I think this font is really sucky um and
I code fine so we went back and forth on
this and we could do source and it looks
pretty decent
then let's do that let's make it look
good let's not let's not be pedantic
about what this means okay all right
I could give you a notebook I don't know
if it'll work okay what else is there to
discuss about these information things
so I feel strongly about the entity case
and I would like to figure out just look
out some of these ooh
Wow and this is basically replicating
the existing classifier information to
make I mean I talked to the machine
learning team but I think that's just
it's too big on this you know given the
size of all this other stuff mm-hmm okay
library function and process their
library information and process
information are both pretty sparse they
are existing information functions but
they don't mean process information
basically just has fine don't worry
about it being too boss but but with
this you know that font is way too big I
don't even understand why it would be so
big you know this may want to be
rear-ended for the information box right
without as many grid lines etc etc etc
you got to ask the machine learning team
okay I would target Jeremy do you want
to comment on this I would target
something about that size may be 0.6 of
the linear dimensions makes sense I'd go
down to half even just fine but then we
may have to I know whether it'll also
proven that the grid lines and so on
okay yeah I can take a look at that
where's the width coming from on that is
that gonna get fixed somehow it doesn't
want a line wrap that list
yeah it's because that'll get fixed
that's because the method option okay is
long but that should be you know but
it's gonna line wrap this yes yeah and
how does the line wrap out Genting and
so on work in terms
the the Indonesian for the next line yes
I'm not sure exactly what you're
referring to yeah I'm saying saying
where does how does it work how does the
letting work and how does it does it
indent to you know if it line wraps yeah
I should indent I think okay and we can
look at letting but it should be nice
and tight okay fine
I just mailed you a mock-up of the that
function list if you want to take a
quick look there's so much to go through
so if you scroll the bottom that source
sands and it's kind of gimme bold verses
um plane for the font weight the bottoms
kind of Bowl it I like that
don't you like that one I was gonna say
I like it I mean especially when you
start collapsing things yeah I ended up
well so I'd like the one above it at
first but the less the kind of the
quantity gets less the more you need
that weight like maybe it looks good
with a lot of functions light but by the
time it's only a couple you want weight
on those function names that felt more
natural at size you have a reasoned
reason why you don't like it
right thing if you did all of rock star
and you know sixty symbols
yeah it's a balance but I do agree that
the first one if you scroll up looks
better in the case of a large quantity
but it's just not a look like that if
you scroll down a little bit that's
source in lighter weight somewhere in
the middle right there so that looks
pretty good with a lot of functions but
it's you know you know yeah out of
curiosity is there a reason that we're
getting two columns instead of like
three or it's based on window width so
I'm guessing yeah right I mean but I've
right now if you do no plot star or
whatever that is is it two columns even
more than that I think it gets
two four or five depend on window with
everything like in the old yeah yes I
mean we're using I think more or less
the same algorithm for determining with
which is looking at father both width
and the length of the symbol I mean this
is always looked okay except for the
line printer background and it's it I
think it's overly big I mean given I
don't think it has to be that big okay
well all right so look I am good with
the the the the heavier font unless we
have really violent objections I suggest
we go with it
um and okay so that's this one let's
just look through some of these others
you
you
okay so down here with these entities we
need a way to indicate that this is the
summary mm-hmm we could either say
parens summary or summary but if entity
is on the right on the left we could say
parens summary on the right okay Jeremy
any comments on that do you think it'll
look stupid I'm worried about how it
read because it's like not in from it's
not describing the information we're
showing it this is the type entity I
hate to put summary up there well okay
but someone is really down here yeah
yeah in the white area or maybe we just
need like a button right just like we
have links right you have more info :
and a button that generates or pops out
a call that I mean I'm not enough in the
weeds of entity anymore to know exactly
what I'm looking at versus what you want
but just dataset it just be that entity
data set I mean we could say entity data
set for example underneath or full
entity data set yes that spits out the
input for that mm-hmm
good night yeah fine let's do it okay
and then my only big objection here is
there's entity property thing which just
you need to talk to somebody from the
entity world about that yeah will do
where we also designed it to be scalable
so other groups can work on setting up
things to the custom for their solutions
although it looks nice okay and these
are defined symbols yes so they're at
the bottom there's the question of so if
you look at question my question mark
number vs. question mark number that's
showing sort of the difference between
person mark and double question mark
right now and I'm contrasting that well
I thought we I'm sorry I thought that we
were in this version that we were
putting the the
context delimiter that that was in a
smaller grayer font is that not correct
that we were putting the context that
that was a general change to formatting
I don't know no you mean just like
normally in notebooks yes that was
something that I had asked to have
happen did it not happen and you know it
was distinguishing we went through this
with John can you find out Sushma can
you find out what happened to that okay
annoying yeah I mean I don't think we
should change that box no no no box
structure change I'm merely talking
about on formatting okay probably yeah
that the rendering of the foo should be
small and smaller and grayer that's all
I'm talking about
wait well okay I mean they're right well
that may not happen automatically and
out in output right because we disabled
show since that styles and output by
default that's not the point I'm talking
about the print form of this being
smaller and grayer that's it I mean the
print form of any no no you could you
Steven right and there are two things
there are only two there are only two
variables there's the boxes and the
rendering and just agreed that the boxes
are can't change which means yup and the
render you know the only reasonable
thing I see here is that you know this
would be controlled by show some
textiles like all the detail let's not
go into that's not right though it
should happen in both cases so it's
there plenty of other like show string
characters being true or false those are
other things okay let's find out
socially should find out why this didn't
happen
okay but meanwhile you had a question
over here right which is so right now
question mark just if there isn't a
usage message question mark the new
question mark is just showing the full
name of the symbol now basically if you
look at the old information for a symbol
if there wasn't a usage message first
symbol it would basically there was no
difference between question mark and
double question mark which on the one
hand is kind of useful because it means
you know if there's actually any
anything there to look at right if or if
it's just a symbol that exists but on
the other hand there's no difference
between us and mark and double question
sorry and and then in this case double
question mark has the second section
opened right right okay
and what is happening now is there a
change that that is a change right so if
you if you go to you an older or even a
master front-end and you type in X
equals 5 and then question mark X right
then you'll you see the definition
because there it's only with when
there's a usage message that there's a
difference between question mark and
double question mark
basically well I
they favor the new behavior where where
the double question mark causes this to
be open and the single question mark
doesn't okay all right well any
objections mmm my main well my main
objection is that it makes it harder to
tell I mean I suppose that just means I
always choose double question mark but
it means that with question mark you
it's it's more difficult to tell us
whether there are any definitions
attached because that's it it's only
hidden if there's a usage message right
no it's sitting precisely when there's
how I see I see I'm sorry I
misunderstood all right because I can
see these things here being high double
but the definition shouldn't be hidden
get what I'm saying if you'd say
question mark X the definition should be
visible maybe some of these details
about full names and attributes maybe I
I don't know you're right you're right
we don't want to hide the definitions so
if the choices hide nothing or hide
everything I would say hide nothing okay
if there's a more nuanced choice then
that would be even better
okay all right okay as we continue right
so one thing we didn't document but I
can eyes producers of this by the way
why is that still oh I see that's an old
version what does it look like a minute
yeah if you open up the next section
that isn't right it couldn't
okay so I haven't oh okay it's because I
see it's it's it's all in the style
Street I can share my screen if you want
to see what is it a prototype built or
not good it isn't the prototype so okay
so I can probably go to the prototype
build
that the private a bill that just icon
just turn normal colored it is the
prototype doesn't still grinding just
launch itself okay much better much
better in my opinion
okay so what should we be looking at
here specifically so if I say I can eyes
of Association Hogg
that isn't the most beautiful rendering
of the the vertical bars and so on and I
think there could be more space with the
dot dots but otherwise that looks fine
that thing looks like some kind of alien
spacecraft right now it's Lewis that an
actual left association and left and
right association characters that's an
image resource okay yeah so let's get
them right yeah um okay uh okay what
other types of cases do we have here
but the inline sequence so do the
arrangement just select it manually
I think the plus needs to be less
notable than the dot dot dot I think the
dot dot dot should be darker okay yeah
and I think I can see that in this case
as well
this behavior is magnificent if you make
the plus lighter is it gonna need a
hover effect it has um I think this is
very nice
very very nice yeah darkening lib dot
dot dots go ahead yep so now that we've
buttered you up with with pretty
pictures let's talk a little bit about
language design yes so all right so so
maybe we should just look at this
holistically so go back to the know I
actually sorry I've got one more point I
think here we should say comment / on
comment I can I slash on I can eyes I
just don't like having the on first
and that by the way will affect the
cloud as well so somebody should take it
there I assume you what the same in the
Edit menu where this appears for real
I'm telling ya yes let's take a look
hmm
very wide there yes well
you
what do you think I think we this is
more survivable because I think you read
the icon eyes selection more here I can
eyes selection is more something you end
up reading then that I can eyes on I can
eyes thing
isn't really necessary in that menu well
yes well why does it not say cut
selection you might ask yes
other than tradition right and actually
complete selection is wrong right
because it doesn't really look at the
selection it looks at the symbol to the
left of the cursor um
okay hold on let's look at this so it
doesn't yeah complete what is it what is
it actually so that's in cases where you
you've disabled automatic then right and
maybe it could just be autocomplete what
doesn't really autocomplete is manually
done here yes and make template this is
the equivalent of the little drop-down
you get after you complete to see the
different templates or maybe you see
them now automatically they don't
remember but yeah okay so listen I don't
think these are quite right this is that
this is something for the user
assistance meeting for this menu but I
think the comment uncomment should be
fixed okay and for right now let's leave
this as uncomment select will only
change the context menu that's correct
for right now and should it be uncomment
with C capital no which means it might
have to go into the spell corrector okay
and same thing for like nice too because
I don't know if people read it does you
need something Oh
recently read an icon Isis unicorn or
unicorn eyes you're right that's not a
winner well spotted I don't think we
should - it well let's look at that well
spotted Sushma that string also appears
in the expanded icon eyes blob that
looks like a deicing
that looks really 1970s who do you want
to change it to icon eyes / expand and
in context that that's clear and then in
the context menu sorry
we've still got the comment uncomment
right I think recognize a word I said we
could say I can eyes toggle comment
toggle yeah toggle though well I guess
through the menu it is yeah I mean why
is they nope why they're not keyboard
shortcuts shown on the right in the
right - in the context menu because it
seems wrong to me can we bring that up a
Lou do you have an answer to that
no let's bring that up in user
assistance please okay and for the
record I don't think I've ever seen
shortcuts in a context menu yeah but
maybe that was just some you know random
thing that Steve Jobs said one day when
the situation was different and
everybody's followed it ever since
possibly I think I don't see why we
don't have
yeah maybe they do okay all right so can
we now get back to you know I hope we
come to a conclusion here are we just
gonna leave this as it is or
I don't like it I really like it um do
we know what state the thing is in when
we when we bring up this menu I don't
think the information is not currently
accessible for the front end no we could
somebody put themselves on yet so we
want the I satellites there people in
the livestream it has to be a verb if
you're okay with the wording in the edit
menu we could use the same wording in
the context menu for now which was what
on I can eyes selection yes comment
selection I agree that's better because
you tend to read the I can eyes
selection altogether fine it's not
fantastic and I would like that on the
user assistance agenda but for 1200 this
will be fine okay okay now it's I you
had further language design issues right
so right so and I can I so organize
produces an itemized object and then
organized object has the which is
currently undocumented although maybe we
should have documented but recognized
object takes an option which is not
currently exposed to nine ayats although
maybe it should be which is sort of a
method you know a method to make it you
know smaller in notebook so if you were
to cool yeah it's a cool idea I think we
should I think we should expose that and
I can eyes at least right and so if you
were to take
one of the the second or third ionized
things there and convert to standards
form in these yeah so take that and
convert to standard form and you'll see
it's a big uncompressed blob because
what you did is you compressed it so
what how do I convert out a stand for
what I might I might toggle to am i dead
yeah you're dead unless you I can eyes
again right so you can
is it still shift control I and he
should be able to undo it also that's
true
no hun who didn't work oh it did work by
the way George and our life's treatments
talking about shortcuts aren't even
you're already in the menu would you
exit the menus use the shortcut the
whole point is that education that you
don't even need to use the menu next
time around here on our live stream is
suggesting I can I slash revert I think
that's super confusing because it's the
revert could mean so many other things
um okay and then the question is should
we let's not for right now we can always
document it later okay I'm just worried
that it might change its structure
sometime what does that second argument
automatic to that's where the label is
stored automatic means the user did not
specify a label but I agree that we we
might well need to change the structure
if we start adding yet more bells and
whistles okay do we have versioning in
the second eyes object anywhere no and
so far we don't need it but if we think
we might be changing it I mean in other
words that method option if I would take
that thing there okay and I would edit
its method option I would just get total
garbage right
I didn't yell at you can you I don't
understand what you what you were I'm
saying if I take the output no longer
has a reference to the method option the
output has a reaction to the method
option I see I see which is itself just
to come on that reverses the method
option an offence right we've changed
the expression that was actually
itemized rather than ionizing expert we
made it be uncompress of the compressed
expression right um okay look I just
don't feel that we thought this through
well enough to document I can eyes dodge
it but with respect to my version in
question are you guys confident because
you are basically self generating a self
unpacking creature that there is no
version in question the only question I
could imagine would be regarding the
visual display the evaluation is is
rock-solid and not changing okay okay
well I mean the visual display uh no
we're not gonna grandfather that if we
change the visual display will change
the raziel display um we probably do
need a night you know a little gallery
of what all the displays are because we
need to get rid of the alien rocketship
thingy here and anything related to that
do we have such a gallery you must have
those image assets I assume that you
that these are these are vector graphics
hey wait a minute what's going on here
why isn't this why isn't this getting
bigger that's wrong what are you doing
I'm doing magnify or increase font size
oh I'm doing increase I'm doing come on
Plus which doesn't magnify you are
correct I am wrong um
furious when you open it up or are we
hard coding the font size yes which is
probably not a bad thing for this case
but if I go here and I say go to 300%
yeah that's fine
that's nice vector graphics that's not a
problem okay all right
listen I think we're over time here we
have alright thank you all very much
thanks to the folks on the livestream
good comments talk Jules